みなさん、ここに犬がいるので
、
フルタイムで仕事をしているので、仕事をどのように
進めていくのかについて、いくつかの発表があります。少しリストを作成
しました。 今後数週間
のコースでやらなければならないこと
や、今後どうなる
かについて話し合う
ので、これをすぐに開いてみましょう。
英語でこれをやり直していることを知って申し訳ありません。
今はこのビデオを日本語に翻訳するのに十分な時間がありません。それについてはすぐに説明し
ます。
そのため、
最初に
APUから数か月間育児休業を取得してから
、辞めました。 仕事ということ
は、今は完全に独立しているということです
が、
ビデオの撮影、ビデオのスクリプト、ビデオの編集、ビデオの編集など、真面目
な仕事に費やす必要のある自由時間の大部分は
、 私は私が経験しないことをしなければなりません ctそれ
は
私が自由になった今
それが大きく変わるとは思わない私はそれが少し変わると思います
私は
apuが投げていたような多くの種類の赤いテープを扱う必要がないことを知っています
アポそれ
は外国人として日本で働くことの一種です
あなたが知っているビザのステータスの変更について入国管理局に相談しなければならなかった
とあなたは私
が地元の市役所に行って
私がどのように必要かについて彼らに話さなければならないことを知っています 会社を通じて
日本の制度にお金を払っていないので、新しい年金プログラムのように申し込む
には、自分で行う必要があり
ます。もう1つは、必要なのは
これらすべての小さなことだけではない
ことです。
私がAPUで働いていなかったとしても、大事
なことは、
前のビデオで述べたように私は双子を持っているので、これ
は少しかもしれないので、私はこれで毎日の大部分を私の子供たちを見なければならないということです 特に双子の子供
がいない人にとっては想像しがたいです
が、ええと、私の
wi  feは家にいて、私もそうですが、
妻はいつも
彼らのために食事を準備したり
、家の周りで洗濯などの仕事をしたりするのに忙しい
ので、彼女がそうしている間、
私はしばしば子供たちを見守らなければなり
ません。
おむつ具体的には入りたくないように変わったの
ですが、要点
は子供の世話をするの
に忙しいので、おそらく
1年くらいで現実的になりそう
です。 それは約1年後、彼らは
おそらくある種の
就学前の就学前の日学校の就学前の
デイケアに行き始めるでしょうが、今は
追加のお金がかかるので、そして
私たちがむしろしたいので、私たちは彼らをどの学校にも入れないようにしています 私は子供たちが寝ている間に今このビデオを録画しているように、毎日の大部分を子供たちを見ているので、私たちができる間は
他の誰かに世話をさせるのではなく、彼らの世話をし
てください
私がolで述べたように常にこれを行います
dビデオ私が言おうとしているのは
、私はとても忙しいということです。過去数か月間
実際にAPUで働いていなかったとしても、
私のスケジュール
は大幅に変わることはないので、
ここにもう少し種類があります。 具体的な
詳細を説明したいので、これから一緒に仕事をするプロの個人会計士を雇った
会計があります。これ
は
かなりスムーズに進むはずですが、ここでも多くのこと
があります。
私を大幅に減速させたさまざまな事務処理の事柄
は、私が独立した今ではほとんどなくなり
、日本での以前のQ＆Aを選択した、より深刻な英語のアドバイスビデオ
を行うことができるようになります。 ある種の
ポッドキャストインタビュースタイルの
一連のビデオを
、APUの元同僚の多くと、
一般の
友人たちと一緒にやっています。
ベッドブーイングに出て、havではなく 日本で
は仕事がうまくいかない
ことは知っていますが、YouTubeや
、日本に住む外国人に影響を与える深い問題や、日本の
外国人が自分自身をどのように認識しているかなど、インターネットでトレーニングしていることを知っています。
そして、彼ら
が彼らの生活
と典型的な平均的な日本人の生活の違いをどの
ように認識しているのか、私は、
雄弁で明確な情報を
与えられ、 日本での生活と仕事の長い歴史が
あるので、その場でできることがたくさんあるので、そのようなビデオをもっと作ることができ
ます
が、少なくともその最初の年のコメディーコンテンツと
音声コンテンツの量は
あまり変化しないので、それが最初のことのひとつです。それ
については、私の
理解がつかないので、ご理解のほどよろしくお願いします。
私が行う編集のほとんどのように話すために、私
は彼らが眠っている間にもう一度撮影し、彼らが眠っ
ている間にスクリプトのように撮影する必要がない日は
いつも編集者から戻ってきたビデオを編集します
生の
カットが好きなのですが、ファイナルカットや
サブタイトル、色補正など
、みんなが寝ているときはいつもそういうことをしている
ので、起きて
いて、フルタイムの仕事をしていなくても、
まだかなり忙しい
ので、その点についてご理解いただきありがとうございます。
他のことについてお話ししたいと思います。
別の変更点として、現在
このオフィスで撮影していて、オフィスのようなものについて話しました。
または
前のことですが、必要な
ときにいつでも撮影できるように、実際にこの部屋を防音する
必要があり
ます。双子がいつ起きるかわからないまま寝ている間も常に撮影して
いるので、声がどれだけ大きいか心配するようなものです。 目を覚ますかもしれません
dそれから、彼らが怒鳴り始めて、私の
妻が両方の世話をすることができないならば、私
は外に出る必要があります、そしてあなたは彼らの世話をすることを知ってい
ます、そしてまた明らかに
彼らの泣き声がここに来るので
これを修正したいと思います オフィスは
少なくともある程度防音になっているので、来週か
そこらでいくつかの会社に
連絡して
それをやってみるつもりです。それ
はカメラにはない仕事の別の例です
が
これをフルタイムでやるには自分の仕事が必要なので
、ごく最近まで仕事をもっと生産的にするために机を大きく変えたいと思っています。
物事があちこちにあるような仮の取引で
、私はただ急いで何かをつかんで
それをどこかに置き、
それから外に出て
双子の世話をしますそして私は戻ってきますそしてあなた
は何かを差し戻すことを知っています
プラグを抜いたか、先に取り出した
ので、これまでにないように物事を合理化しようとして
います 少し
いいので、三脚用に机に穴を開けて、机
の上ではなく直接机に光を
当てることができます。
後でこれについてビデオを作るとき、それ
はまた別のことです。私に
は非常に雑多な
健康上の問題が
たくさんあるのを見てみましょう。それは、
私が武道を騙していた
ためです。 本当に悪い関節がたくさんある
ので、
捻挫した足首の残留物や、指
や骨のつま先の骨折などがあります。
肩関節脱臼や半月板損傷
など、さまざまな問題があるので
、過去に膝のように話しました。 あまり良くないですが
、膝
は以前よりずっと良くなって
いますが、実際には背中に半月板があり、
それもかなり
難しくなってい
ます。これからやりたいことは、
世話をすることです。 私が持っているよりも自分自身が良いb
ええと、過去に、これについて話すのは好きではありません。
なぜなら、それは
不平を言う
ようなものであり、YouTubeでの時間を使って不平を言うのは好きではないからです。
しかし、椎間板ヘルニアがあると言ったことはあり
ません。
視聴者に見てもらいたいもの
私の作品を見てもらい
たい私の冗談ですが、それは私が扱ってきた
ものであり、もっと真剣に
仕事ができるように恒久的に修正する
ために最善を尽くしたいと思います。 座っていると背中が痛いので、
10分ごとに休憩する必要はありません。
映画館で座って映画全体を見ることができます。
背中が
痛くて叫ぶようなことはありません。 でも、これを録音した
直後に、実際に医者に行っ
て、背中を
見てもらい、
最近、小指が小指になっているので、指を見て
もらいます。この手は
少し痛いです。 何
人かの皆さんに聞いてみたかったのです
だから私はAppleユーザーです私は
Apple製品が本当に好きですが、彼らの
キーボードはこれを知っている人もい
ますが、それは非常に目立たず
、マウスでもある
ので、彼らのマウスは確か
にキーボードよりも優れていますそれはあまり
人間工学的ではありません デザインに基づいている
ので、このように保持する必要があります。
私は
、このジョイントを知っているので、それをつかんでつまんで保持するようなものであることに気付き
ました。それが問題の原因だったと思います。
確かにそうであるかどうかは
わかりますが、現在使用しているトラックパッドを左手で購入することで対処しました。
生産性にはそれほど影響していませんが
、視聴者全員に聞いてみたいと思います。 私はたまたまサイズの
点でかなり大丈夫な聴衆を持っています
これは関節に悪いです機械的なキーボードのように切り替えることで問題を少し軽減する
ことができた関節の痛みや指の痛みのような経験を持っている人はい
ます
か 人々が本当に
メカに夢中になっていることを知っている icalキーボードですが、これは、
一般的な
生産性が、
このAppleキーボードの上に、
非常に薄くて問題の少ないメカニカルキーボードを使用するような感じのようなものだと思います。
この問題の背景がある場合は、
間違いなく役立つ可能性があります。 悪化する前に
この問題に対処したいので、私に知らせ
てくださいええと、他に話したいことがあるかどうかを見てみましょう。
独立した私はまた、
あなたの
誰かが、
今後フルタイムで働くことになる誰かとして
私に役立つと思うような一般的なアドバイスを持っているかどうかを皆さんに尋ね
たいと思いました。 日本で働いて生活しているが、
起業家で
あるか、自営業である
か、過去
にワークフローに変更を加えた
ことが重要であるかのように自営業であるかのように、一人で働いている 物事をスピードアップする私は
、キーボードショートカットが
編集プログラム内であろうと、Gmail内であろうと、
非常に
優れていることに注意したいと思います。
一般的な生産性の観点から、
私はおそらく多くの恩恵を受けることができると思う
ので、あなたの誰かが
再び特定の作業習慣や特定のプログラムを採用した場合
、私は私のMacでAlfredも使用しています。 それは
確かに大きなゲームチェンジャーですが
、素敵な椅子のように購入することを知っているかどうか、またはアドバイスが
あれば一般的な生産性を向上させるものであるかどうかにかかわらず、コンピューターから作業を行うことに関する一般的
なアドバイスはありますか？
確かに
気づいていないことがあるので、聞いてみたいと思い
ます。今気づいたら、次の時間の節約になる可能性があります
。34 5 6 7 8 910年
そうですね、一般的なアドバイス
は、日本に関する
ものである
必要はまったくありません。
そのようなことを聞いたことがあれば、
生産性を向上させるような一般的な作業を行うだけです
。 明日の医者の今日は、このような理由で防音防音ができる
かどうか、改革会社に連絡してみよう
と思います。また、市役所に
行って世話をする必要があります。 年金の事務処理など
で、現在の勤務スケジュールが約2〜3日遅れると予想
していますが、YouTubeのコメディコンテンツにはあまり影響しません。
これは、次の音声
を予想していることを常連客に知らせるためのものです。
レッスン
が約2日遅れてしまったので、
お詫び申し上げますが、これから行う
すべての変更が
私に利益をもたらし、
非常に大きな意味で今後も非常に大きな意味を持つと確信しています。
ありがとうございました。
その点で
、私が実際に
フルタイムで働くように移行している今、
私が遭遇しているほんの少しの摩擦のような道路の隆起があることを理解しているので、ええ、それは約15分です。
基本的にこのビデオで言いたかったのは
、このビデオの
撮影を開始する直前に、Twitterで
トレンドの何かを見たということです。
日本のTwitter
はハッシュタグのようなものでした。なぜ死ぬか髪を切る必要があるのですか？
公立学校と呼ばれる日本語では伝統的ではない伝統的な日本の学校実際に
ほとんどの学校は学生
に完全に黒いストレートの髪
を要求します 面白いと
思ったので、この特定のテーマについて1分間の話を簡単に説明
します。つまり、外国人をたくさん見たことがあるということです。
人種差別の例としてのこの問題についての過去の話
と人々はあなた
が多分私が混合娘を
持っているか私が混合息子を持っていて彼らが髪を染めなければならなかったことを知っているとよく言い
ますがそれは間違いなく本物だと思います
それは
確かにそれらすべての人々に影響を及ぼします、
そして私はそれ
から来たものから来た彼らの苦しみを減らそうとはし
ていません
が、これについてコメントしている人々の大多数が
ツイッターは100％自然な
日本人
な
ので、少し茶色の髪の日本人がたくさんいるので
、この機会に
、お父さんのようになりたくないということを簡単に思い出させていただきたいと思います。
父かその
ようなものですが、
多くの外国人は
彼らに影響を与えている問題にズームインする傾向があり、そうしている間
、同じ問題または
その問題の異なる変化がしばしば影響を与えることを忘れることが多いことに
気づきました 日本人も
そうですが、これは
確かに外国人と日本人の半分
が影響を受けた外国人学生
を抱えていることの良い例だと思いますが、確かに多く
の日本人もそうです。 日本で一般的な生活をしている
ことを知っているという問題には、複数の兆候があることを改めて認識して
いるのは
良いことです。特に日本の外国人にとっては、それは常に心に留めておくべきことだと思います。
多くの場合、あなたはsalutelyのように文句を言うだろう知っていて、種類のIは減少誰の苦しみにはしたくないけどただ、私は確かに日本では外国人は、多くの場合、日本の人々に直面し、私だけ、私に影響を与えるものに焦点を当て、多くの問題を忘れるよう 成長して成長する
ええ、本当に小さな問題について不平を言う
ことがよく
ありますが、時々、
このようなものを目にします。
あまり気づいていない問題がたくさんあるので、
とにかく簡単に話をしたいと
思います。ご支援ありがとうございます。本当にたくさんの意味が
あります。
すぐには理解できないことをご理解いただきありがとうございます。
毎日のようにコメディービデオを押し出し始めるので、それ
は私には少し難しい
でしょうが、IIは、私が以前
に話したインタビューポッドキャストスタイルのビデオで、私
の
一般的な頻度を
実際にどれだけ頻繁に増やすつもりです 動画を公開し
ておりますので、今後ともよろしくお願い申し上げます。またお話しできる
ことを楽しみに
しております。